stalker is one of my favorite shows of
all time and today I want to share with
you five of my most favorite episodes
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
Children of the Gods is the first
episode of Stargate sg1 following on one
year after the events of the original
movie
in this episode we get to meet the main
antagonist of the first two seasons
Apophis and it's when we get to see tilt
effect from his role as the first Prime
to Apophis
as a two-part special combined into one
Children of the Gods is essentially the
second Stargate movie and was in my
opinion the perfect episode to get
started with the Stargate television
series
[Music]
I can save these people
help me
help me
many have said that
[Music]
could do it
the next episode on my list is Servant
Song
my surfing song is one of if not the
greatest episode of season two
in it we can see Apophis crashing his
ship after fleeing Soca and seeking
Refuge with the Towery
Peter Williams the actor who plays
Apophis in this episode is phenomenal as
we get to see two sides of his character
that being the Arrogant pompous Goa old
side and the weak scared and vulnerable
side of his host
the fact that the host emerged after
essentially being trapped in what he
describes as an endless nightmare really
cements the fact that something of the
host does survive and gives Daniel
Jackson the hope he needs to carry on
searching for his wife Chari
[Music]
help me
no
a host
no
I am afraid
[Music]
a wonderful opportunity is probably the
most popular episode of Stargate of all
time essentially a reimagining of
Groundhog Day with sci-fi elements Jack
and teok are stuck in a Time Loop caused
by an archaeologist trying to go back in
time to be with his wife
as Jack until the only two people who
are aware of the of the loop they have
to assist Daniel Jackson in translating
an endless wall of ancient text this
episode is important for the fact as
without it I don't think they would have
grasped the ancient language as quickly
as they did
the episode is one of the most hilarious
episodes of Stargates whoever as being
stuck in a Time Loop had an effect on
Jack where he essentially gave up and
decided to do whatever he wanted
from Pottery to riding his bike through
the SGC and golfing through the Stargate
this is one of the most quoted episodes
of sg1 with lines like in the middle of
my backswing being one of the more
popular
[Music]
sorry sir I didn't realize
in absolute power we see the harsis
child once again a child born of two
grow old with all the genetic memories
of the gold who came before it
this was the conclusion of a couple of
Seasons as Daniel Jackson had been
helping the hasis child previously who
he later took to Keb and ultimately the
child was helped by omadisala and
ascended to a higher plane of existence
but on his return He gave Daniel Jackson
a glimpse into what having all of the
knowledge of the Goa award would do to
him
we see Daniel gradually change
throughout this episode as a result of
the knowledge and as he grows in power
we see the negative effects that are
present with Olga award
the knowledge essentially turns him into
a power hungry lunatic who ultimately
ends up turning the weapons he had made
on the people of Earth
this teaches Daniel a very valuable
lesson as all of this was a dream
created by the artist's child this is
one of the greatest episodes ever
absolutely fantastic and as a standalone
story for Daniel Jackson one of the best
my final episode in this list is Lost
City part 2 which is the series 7 finale
in which Anubis are half ascended
guarald is wading war on Earth
the team who had found an ancient
Outpost in Antarctica are trying to
activate the ancient chair with the help
of Jack who had absorbed all the
knowledge of the Ancients again
in it we get to see the first glimpses
of the Prometheus the first battle ready
ship of the Towery in action for the
very first time and ultimately see the
destruction of Anubis and his Fleet
thanks to the drones that were activated
by the ancient chair as a series finale
this is the absolute best as it takes to
Towery from a simple Explorer going
through the gates with full force
equipped with their own ships this is a
major moment for the Atari and for these
reasons it's one of my most favorite
episodes of all time
more ships approaching from the opposite
direction
sir we're about to get around
defend that scholarship at all cost
s
Prometheus
yes sir it's good to see you and there
you have it my top five Target episodes
of all time thank you so much for
watching if you did enjoy the video make
sure you hit subscribe and press the
Bell notification so you don't miss a
single video whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching and I
will see you next week
[Music]